cette semaine nous avons eu une petite
annonce dans libération nous a semblé
amusante elle disait à peu près ceci
jeune femme de 19 ans très jolie cherche
messieurs super sympa rendez vous à la
sortie du métro richard lenoir à midi le
mardi avec libération sous le bras
n'écoutant que votre courage nous sommes
rendus sur place avec notre caméra il
est 11 heures 25
déjà on voit arriver quelques clients
tenant à la main libération traîne sa
marotte sur la place 11h30 arrivée d'un
vétéran alors lui bille en tête qui
s'installe carrément devant le métro à
la librairie on ne comprend plus rien
j'aimerais bien savoir pourquoi on nous
a demandé des libérations en quantité
straw nomique on vous en a demandé
beaucoup on m'a demandé où au moins 25
alors qu'habituellement genre en cinq
ans et au moins une cinquantaine de
personnes déjà sur la place qui font les
cent pas 11h45
le vétéran affiche ses opinions on
attend on discute on fait connaissance
on lit son journal et on patiente
il est midi à midi est vraiment beaucoup
de monde sur la place mais toujours pas
de brigitte en vue serait cette dame où
celle ci ou celle là sûrement pas
c'est le moment que nous choisissons
pour envoyer notre apa en l'occurrence
une de nos collaboratrices équipé avec
un micro soigneusement dissimulé elle
s'approche de la sortie du métro et à la
tan pourquoi pas
hop une touche
pas d'objets non je m'appelle pas
brigitte devenu bull annonce
qu'annonce comment libération nous et on
se concerte elle attend le vétéran s'en
va sur la place on se pose des questions
qui râlent premier suprême provocation
elle sort libération salle ou pas qui
avait passé une annonce l'arrivée pour
nordine hiddink et leurs noms annoncés
dans libé d'une fille qui attendait des
mecs à midi six mois au bout d'un moment
il ya vraiment beaucoup de points alors
je décide d'intervenir
[Musique]
il faut se rendre à l'évidence brigitte
nous a posé un lapin
et si certains ont pu établir un
dialogue c'est quand même moi qui
embarquait notre collaboratrice et ça
tombait bien puisque c'était ma femme
quoi qu'il en soit c'est une affaire à
suivre
[Musique]